Keynesian economics was a snare and
delusion in the 50s 60s and 70s we're
going to find that it's a it was a snare
and delusions and the O's and and the
teens
once the stimulus package was announced
in was not yet specified there were
groups all over this country spending
real resources in order to figure out
how they could get some of this money
there was a Chancellor level contact
force put together on the University of
California Irvine campus to try to
figure out what they could put on a
stimulus list the thing that most people
don't realize is that yes the
professor's on this campus are getting
the 42 million there's some graduate
students that are going to be employed
as a result of that where did the 42
million come from did it just to send
like manna from heaven it could very
well have come from other projects that
it would been more productive and more
worthy the typical research scientists
on this campus makes twice the median
household income maybe three times and
we have professors on this campus
they're making six seven eight times the
median household income their maids in
Santa Monica who are paying taxes
federal taxes in one form or another to
help fund the lifestyle of professors
who live a very good lifestyle i have to
say because of the steps we took there
about two million americans working
right now who would otherwise be
unemployed 300,000 our teachers and
other education workers tens of
thousands are cops firefighters
correctional officers first responders
what you hear in the press and from the
Obama administration is one side of the
argument that is if we take if the
federal government takes money and goes
over here and buy his cars or buys
houses or by us or whatever that's going
to cause jobs over here to be created
and you can see those jobs there but
what is never mentioned in this in this
debate is something milton friedman used
to harp on all the time and that is
where does the federal government get
the money that it's spent and the secret
is that they go out and they borrow the
money and if they borrow the money that
means they take money away from other
projects that would have been undertaken
had the federal government not sucked up
all of these lendable funds the problem
with the with some of the stimulus money
is we've reactivated the view that some
firms are too big to fail well most
people don't realize that that means
that firms are going to become too big
because if in fact you you say firms
that are big have proposed a systemic
risk to the economy that means those
firms are going to be able to attract
investment dollars at a cheaper rate
than firms that are smaller and the
bigger firms are going to grow and
they're going to be even to bigger begin
with the threat of the deficit the
dollar the stability of the dollar can
can unravel all can depreciate which
means that in the future you have a
taxation to higher price of imports and
I don't think people realize that that
the United States government can become
the next Greece it can become the next
California if it goes off on profligate
spending sprees as it apparently has
done and it and we just don't have this
the stimulus thing to concern with is it
once you open up uncork you know DC for
stimulus packages you uncork it for
doing all kinds of other things we
should put more Americans to work
building clean energy facilities
and give and get rebates to Americans
who make their homes more
energy-efficient I'm considering putting
solar panels online office shed that I
have at home why because one-third of
cost of it is going to be covered by
various programs and I've been told that
I might be able to get the whole thing
covered I get electricity I can then
pretend to all my colleagues look I've
got solar panels I'm green but in fact
I'm probably damaging the economy
because I'm soaking up more resources
than I would have needed to soak up and
I use some other less green technology
if in fact green technology were
cost-effective than then of course it
could be a good idea but if in fact it
would cost effective you wouldn't need
all these subsidies or do remember that
the federal deficit this year I think
it's 1.7 trillion dollars forty-three
percent of the federal budget the
federal debt is 14 trillion with
prospects of its going to 20 trillion by
2015 and that's probably that's the
government's official official estimate
so you can probably guess it will
actually go further and we have the
threat of health care reform packages
that can be extraordinarily expensive
and unfunded and combine all of these
things that we have we have the threat
of higher taxes on their horizons
especially for for higher income groups
who generally speaking are the people
here
I productive the best economic course
two years ago actually going into last
year would have been just to let things
rip and I know that comes as as somehow
harsh somebody whose job is very secure
I've got lifetime employment here at the
University of California Irvine but at
the same time the issue is whether the
medication is worth worse than the
disease we're into a recovery but I
think it has very little to do with with
the stimulation that the government has
provided it has more to do with the fact
that you had a lot of people out there
who are unemployed who have resources
that are unemployed and they faced
hardship and they've started to find
ways to redeploy themselves and their
resources in in constructive ways who's
to say that the political process can
actually be more effective in bringing
about a recovery than a market process
in the case of the political process
we're relying on the 535 people in
Congress and a few thousand people
around Obama in the market process we're
going to be relying on 308 million
people and I ask you where is the
greater collective brains the silver
lining maybe that we're going to prove
that government is far more impotent in
reviving the economy than we
been led to believe in the long run in
the very long run Cannes is going to be
dead fine